i mean it was an escalation because you
had not just um
you know one person trump or his
supporters
being ghosted or d platform but you had
16 million parlor users or whatever is
99.9
of whom never did anything wrong you
know and that was a diminishment of
their free speech rights
um it was also i think unjustified
uh if if the justification for that
was that parlor was used in the planning
of the events of january 6 it was
clearly a scapegoating because
um we now have fbi charging documents
that come out they found
226 cases the social networking site
that was used 10x more than all the
others was facing
you know parlor was used one tenth of
the amount that facebook was but
parlor was you know was sort of an easy
and easy target to sort of scapegoat for
that
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the former ceo
of paypal an angel investor in such
companies as facebook
uber and spacex the founder of craft
ventures
and a co-host of the all-in podcast
david sacks welcome to the reuben report
great to be here
i'm glad to have you you know when i was
looking through all your bios
and wikipedia which i'm sure is all
perfectly true and all that good stuff
there's a lot of stuff i could have
pulled there for the bio and i was
thinking for the
for my young audience watching this like
basically being part of all of those
things
kind of seems like the coolest thing
possible
so how does somebody get into all of
that
yeah i mean i was lucky to uh graduate
stanford in
1994 which was the year before the
internet really kind of took off
and i was lucky enough to meet peter
thiel when i was there
and we collaborated together on you know
we both worked on the
the student newspaper the sort of
conservative libertarian student
newspaper that peter founded and then we
ended writing a book together
and he recruited me years later to join
paypal
and um you know i actually thought i had
missed the whole
internet thing and then i got a call
from peter in 1999
and he told me about this company he was
creating
and uh you know that that company went
on to become paypal and he recruited me
to be the ceo
so yeah that's how i got into it yeah do
you think peter
or you or elan like did anyone realize
what any of this stuff
was gonna become or just when it's
unfolding you just kind of run with it
and see what happens
you know it at the time we we sort of
knew on it like a certain level that it
was
changing the world like at paypal we had
this
user counter that would track the user
growth we called it the world domination
index
so on a certain level we kind of you
know
thought it was taking over the world but
on another level we didn't
quite you know understand it it felt a
little bit like fantasy or something
so so yeah it was like you know it it it
definitely operated on both levels
yeah how much of paypal was just trying
to get people to like
understand you could do things
differently like i i literally remember
the first time i saw paypal i had moved
into a new apartment with a couple
roommates i was a struggling comic i
barely had any money
and one of my roommates said to me you
got to pay me on paypal for the rent
and i i didn't even know what that meant
like the idea that i could link
a bank account to something online and i
don't even think we had wi-fi yet like
it was still
wired at all like just getting people to
like understand there's new ways of
doing things like how much of it is just
that
well a big part of it and then the the
other big part of it was just making it
really easy to actually do it
so you know we it's a lot easier now we
didn't have all the tools
you know that we that we have now 20
years ago and
so just getting the product to be super
simple so you could put in an email
address put in your credit card number
and it would
send the money and then you'd get it
build a teacher ban count i mean it
sounds really easy but
there's all this friction in the way
that have to be removed and i think part
of the reason why we're successful is we
were able just to make it like
incredibly simple
yeah so you mentioned the diversity myth
and i've
i've talked to peter on the show and you
guys wrote this book
1995. in essence
you you wrote this at stanford you guys
kind of predicted
everything that was happening that's
happening right now like really
the idea that that sort of the the
diversity of immutable characteristics
would matter more than the diversity of
thought
which we now see just rampaging through
all our businesses and institutions and
the political sphere and everything
how did you guys see it coming we had we
had been
you know writing on the the stanford
review and stanford was sort of the
epicenter that
there was a famous protest in 1988 where
jesse jackson led a letter a a mob that
was chanting hey hey ho ho western
culture's gotta go
so stanford was sort of the the
epicenter for
for a lot of that stuff and um so we
were writing about it as
a student journalist in a way and that
book was an extension of the
student journalism we had done um you
know looking back i mean i was a
teenager when
uh we wrote a lot of that i wouldn't
actually make all the same arguments the
same way that i did back then but i do
think
we were ahead of the curve in realizing
you know this
um this growing a liberalism you know
this this sort of political correctness
now it's
you know called cancer culture where uh
where
you know we're putting restrictions on
people's ability to speak and to think
and
uh to express themselves in ways that i
think would have been
um that that certainly you know 1960s
liberals
wouldn't have um you know wouldn't have
supported
and so you know i never i never honestly
saw myself as a conservative i saw
myself as more of like a 1960s style
liberal
who believed in free speech and you know
a colorblind society
i i know the feeling man we're on a
similar
journey here yeah with issues um
but yeah i mean you know it was the
illiberalism
on campus that sort of pushed me to
become
more politically aware and uh you know
and that's what the book was about
and now really the whole country is like
um it was like andrew sullivan says we
all live on campus now
right because it's kind of funny to me
you guys were writing about this in 95
and say when i was talking about some of
this stuff
five years ago so you know 20 years
after you wrote about it
people kept saying to me no no it's just
going to stay on campuses
and when they get to the real world the
real world
will show them and uh no
those students graduated you know and uh
and they took those ideologies
into the places where where they went
and uh
so you know they took them to the you
know a lot of those graduates went off
to run
school boards or to run uh you know
newspapers the new york times and you
know places like that i mean this is
it's a very elite um uh
philosophy or ideology that's being um
imposed and it's it's coming from places
like you know stanford and other
uh ivy league type type schools yeah so
you've been big on sort of the three
topics that
at least for me at the moment are are my
big three topics which are
are big tech covid and then california
specifically because i think there's
covid at a sort of national and
worldwide level and then california so
we'll hold that for a moment but on the
big tech
stuff you know i started talking about
free speech a couple years ago
and then there was suddenly this feeling
that we were kind of being censored but
we couldn't figure it out then we
started hearing
phrases like shadow banning and
de-boosting
and algorithmic fairness all of these
things
and i think one of the things that
people wonder about is how
this all infected all of
seemingly all of the big tech companies
yeah you have any theories on where it
sort of started in there
and and how it became so inclusive
yeah well i think you know the the
technology industry isn't
is primarily based in silicon valley and
most of the people
are are pretty liberal and so there
there will be sort of that that liberal
skew but
it but from i'd say most of the
evolution of these big tech companies
they saw themselves as neutral uh
platforms
uh and they they didn't see themselves
as partisans engaged in a political
battle
um they merely wanted to create the the
tools and the platforms for other people
to communicate
and i think something changed if i had
to sort of pinpoint
when it changed it would have been
around 2016
um you know when when trump got elected
i think that
a lot of big tech bought into the
argument that they had
sort of caused uh trump to to be elected
or you know that that sort of
disinformation
you know had been used through their
platforms and this had resulted in
the election of trump and so therefore
they could no longer just be
neutral they would have to take
corrective measures
to prevent this uh this disinformation
and i think that was sort of the the
beginning of it where
again the the the i think
big tech sort of bought into this idea i
think they were predisposed to buying
into it because
they were liberal but they were never as
partisan
as they subsequently became over the
last few years
it's not that dissimilar from i think
what happened with the news industry you
know there were people
like brent bizzell for years who were
doing studies showing that 90 plus
percent of reporters
were liberal voted democrat and so on
but they
believed in a a code a journalistic code
of objectivity or neutrality
and somehow you know over over the last
four years trump was perceived as such a
threat
that you know the media decided that was
more important to stop trump than to
live up to the sort of this code of
of neutrality and i think something
similar happened in big tech as well
yeah has it been tough for you as
someone that isn't
purely a leftist regardless of how you
fully define yourself but you're not
you're clearly not purely leftist
but to be in san francisco and and still
be around a lot of that i mean right now
we know that a ton of people
the whole the whole biz the whole
industry is fleeing to miami miami's
looking pretty good right now to have
some open conversations
well yeah i mean so no i mean there's
been no
reprisals or anything like that but i do
think that people feel
like they can't say you know exactly
what they think i do think that people
feel um uncomfortable expressing a view
that's not the
prevailing you know the prevailing views
and uh
so for me part of the reason why i
started doing the all in pod and start
speaking out more is just to show people
that they could speak out
because the gap between what makes sense
and what people feel comfortable has
never been greater
i mean if you look back on 2020 i mean
just to name a few issues
i mean these protracted lockdowns that
you know aren't
substantiated by science i mean they're
just kind of crazy
the idea of defunding or abolishing the
police i mean
you can you know believe that we need to
have controls on the use of violence by
police but just to
say that we should just abolish the
police or or
um or or defund them or to empty out the
jails as a which is happening now in in
san francisco and and
we'll get to your d.a in a little bit
don't worry about that
just for me but but what struck me is
not just like that these ideas are just
so
crazy and sort of off-base but just that
nobody felt comfortable
saying these things and so i felt a
little bit of an obligation to speak out
more
because you know economically i you know
i
if i get cancelled i'm still going to be
fine you know um
i'm not i'm in um i'm in a position
where
i mean i don't know if i can be canceled
but um but if i can i might you know
economically i'm gonna be fine so um so
i felt like we need
more people to speak up you know speak
out so that everybody feels comfortable
and they don't feel like they're just
going crazy
if they're you know not in favor of of
defunding the police or something like
that
yeah are you are you surprised that in
the silicon valley world there aren't
more people i mean there's plenty of
people that i think have a little more
libertarian approach to the to the world
i think
all of you guys you like business you
like competition you like capitalism all
of those things
and there are plenty of people that are
at least somewhat financially secure
that that still are pretty quiet because
they'll
reach out to me privately but then
they're like no no no i'm not going to
go on the show
yeah so it's funny the the latest
episode so i do a pod with
uh i'll be all in pod with three other
friends in silicon valley we all play
poker together that's
hence the name all in and it's it's a
sort of a mix of people across the
political spectrum
uh but on the last episode we were
joking that it was sort of the red pill
episode
because we were talking about uh
california and we were talking about
crime in san francisco we were talking
about
um the protracted lockdowns um
we were talking about the newsome recall
and pretty much everybody on the pod
you know all four of us were basically
espousing positions that you could say
were
you know uh so that i don't even know if
they were to the right of center but
they were sort of you know
red build and so i think there is kind
of now
um i think more of a willingness of
people
well i don't know if it's a willingness
to speak out but i definitely think
there's a lot more people
who feel the way that we do that things
have gone too far
um and i think part of it is also that
with trump off the scene
it does depressurize the situation to
some degree
for you know like some of the you know
one or two of the guys
on our pod um i would describe as having
tds for sure
you know and uh you know now that he's
that
he's sort of cured of his trump
derangement syndrome he's
um you know he's speaking out about uh
the the d.a and and san francisco as
much as anybody so
so yeah i mean i think that that changes
things a little bit yeah all right so
before we go too
far down the california thing and i know
you've got all kinds of issues
uh with your d.a up there and you have
challenged him to a debate we'll see if
it actually
actually happens but i i just thought we
could go into some of like the basic
stuff
about big tech that i think people are
confused by so you've written a bunch
about
section 230 of the communications act
and i thought maybe could you just kind
of clean it up for people because i hear
a lot of people saying oh trump should
have invoked 230 and now it's too late
and we should do it we shouldn't do it
but
basically in your in your medium article
you make the argument it's a little more
nuanced
perhaps than than just invoking it or
getting rid of it or whatever else
yeah the call that you're hearing by
conservatives
is that they want to repeal texas
section 230 which is the liability
shield that protects big tech companies
and
and what that liability shield does is
that when somebody
uh posts content on their platforms that
would
normally give rise to liability you can
only sue the person who posted it not
the platform so
it's a little bit like the distinction
between a magazine
and a newsstand you know if the magazine
publishes an article that's defamatory
then the magazine can be sued but the
newsstand
on which the magazine is sold cannot be
sued it did not participate in the
creation of that content
it merely distributed it that was the
distinction that section 230
sought to establish it basically said
that these big tech companies and really
all tech companies this doesn't just
apply to the big ones but to small
innovators as well
they're protected as long as all they're
doing is distributing
um as long as they're not creating the
content they're
and i think there's a lot of that makes
a lot of sense because
you couldn't have um restaurant reviews
on yelp
you know if if yelp could be sued every
time
you know a small business didn't like
the review you know you would have um
you know reddit was sued recently
because people in a comment board lost
money
on one of the trades that was you know
that was posted in wall street bets
and so you know and so you know gmail
gmail
maybe would be imperiled if google be
sued every time a crime was committed
using gmail right and so it doesn't make
sense to always hold the
the tech platform liable for any content
that the user is posting you should
really go after those
those users that part of section 230
which is sort of as perfect
provision 230 c1 that still i think
makes
a lot of sense and if you were to get
rid of it sort of throw the baby out
with the bathwater
i think you would hurt a lot of small
innovators there's a lot of small
tech companies that rely on that
liability protection
to offer their service the problem is
that
it all came in with section uh c2 which
basically
this is it's really interesting this is
where congress
this is where um you know the road to
hell is paid with good intentions
what congress tried to do in c2 was say
the big tech companies listen we
we don't want to punish you for being
good samaritans so if you want to take
down content on your site
because it's pornographic it's it's
obscene
it's excessively violent or otherwise
objectionable
you can take that down and we won't hold
you to be a publisher you'll still stay
say you'll stay a new stand in our eyes
and so you know congress tried to to
congress was very worried this was 1996
when the the act was called the
communications decency act and
they were very worried about sort of
smut on the internet and they were
trying to give tech companies
uh an incentive or protection to remove
this type of objectionable content
without then triggering liability and so
but see this is where all the censorship
concern
has now come in because fast forward 15
years later
and big tech companies are using this
very broad term otherwise objectionable
to mean content that they simply don't
like that you know politically they
don't like it
and so they now have all the censorship
power and this is where all the problems
come in
this is why you know trump and others
have called for their appeals section
230.
i understand that um
the desire because i think the
censorship is wrong
but i just think that we need a we need
a slightly different solution
right so do you have a sense of what
goes on
at the board meetings of these companies
when they're trying to make these
policies because i think a lot of people
think and i've tried to get my audience
off this
idea that it's just a couple of guys
sitting there and they all hate
conservatives
and and the goal is just to destroy
conservatives because i don't think it's
that simple i think it's much more
complex
than that but what would be like a
sensible policy because it seems
fairly obvious you you can see it in in
twitter trends you know i screen capture
them all the time and it's
very obvious when they're actually
sometimes they're actually trying
to push a mob towards somebody um
so what would be a sensible policy that
you think would be
would be honest and and legal
i suppose well i'm pretty happy with the
first amendment
you know um i think the first amendment
and 230 years of supreme court case law
provides us
with the standard and the supreme court
for two centuries has been wrestling
with the problem of dangerous speech and
there are
i think there's a misconception that the
first amendment allows
anything goes it doesn't there are at
least nine categories of speech that are
not
protected by the first amendment because
they're dangerous you cannot
yell fi you know fire in a crowded
theater you cannot
incite people to commit a crime uh you
can't engage in fraud you know you can't
per you can't defame somebody um they're
you know fighting words are illegal so
there's a lot of categories of speech
that that aren't protected and
most of the speech that causes social
networks the greatest problems
they fall into one of those categories
and so i think it would be
very doable for them to create
a content moderation policy that is
broadly consistent
with the first amendment now the reason
why i say broadly is because look we're
like take defamation for example we're
not going to do a court
trial every time that a user complains
that they're being harassed by another
user right okay
what we're going to do is we're going to
have a standard that says that if
a user complains about another user's
post and that post
is facially defamatory about that other
user we're going to take it down because
there are billions of these social media
posts and we're not going to run a trial
every time
but we're going to take our guidelines
from
first amendment case law and those are
basically going to be the broad
categories
what we're not going to do is create new
categories
of speech that are prohibited
because that would appropriate to the
big tech companies
uh uh extraordinary power you know um
but do you but do you think the problem
do you think the inherent problem is
that because
so much of the social justice stuff has
now leaked into these companies
that you know i can get on board what
you just said most of my audience can
get on board what you
what you just said but they can't
because they've accepted
this ideology that many ways is just
completely counter to that
i think ideology is very motivating
especially for a lot of the
low-level employees who've banded
together and created pressure on the
leadership the management of these
companies um they've you know created
these these campaigns these boycotts
there's also pressure coming from above
uh from the senate uh judiciary
committee and that committee basically
you know in these hearings the the
people who are now
uh the the the leading members of that
committee uh
keep basically are telling big tech uh
on the one hand we want you to censor
more and on the other we're thinking
about breaking you up
and um and so there's a lot of pressure
i think
on that big tech is feeling that if they
don't go along
with these policies that either they're
gonna you know anger the people
above um and and that may increase the
chances they get you know busted up
or that they will you know they're gonna
upset sort of this pressure that's
coming from below from the employees
um i don't think it's a very good excuse
by the way i think they should have
more courage and backbone than that i
think our commitment to
free speech should be made of sterner
stuff than that yeah but i think the
reality is that these companies are
you know succumbing to pressure
campaigns what do you think just broadly
about
just the amount of power that they have
over us because you mentioned the first
amendment before
i don't think the founders could have
ever imagined that there would basically
be four
companies that in many ways i think you
could argue are more powerful than the
government at least in our day-to-day
lives
at this point like what do we do about
that amount of power
they do have an extraordinary amount of
power because what happened is the town
square got privatized
free speech got digitized that caused
the town square to get
privatized and the first amendment got
euthanized um
you know because you know when the when
the framers of the constitution wrote
the first amendment
where did you go for free speech there
were a multiplicity of town squares all
over the country there were thousands of
them
you could get on the courthouse steps
pull out your soapbox you could speak
and anyone who wanted to listen could
gather around that's why
the first amendment contains not just
right to free speech but a right to
peacefully assemble
well where do people assemble today on
these massive social networks which have
gigantic network effects
that is where you go to be heard and if
you cannot express yourself on one of
these social networks
to what extent do you still have a free
speech right in this country i don't
think you do
and what we saw what we were seeing you
know since since the election
is that you effectively have a cartel of
these big
tech companies coming together making
identical decisions to deny people their
free speech rights
and you know again to what extent do you
really have
a first amendment right in this country
when the town square has been privatized
and you've been
you know de-platformed can you talk a
little bit about how you think that
cartel works because
you've written a little bit about this
like when trump got taken out after
january 6 when they took him off spotify
and pinterest and twitter and youtube
you know it wasn't even the ones where
he was it's like okay now he can't
listen to music anymore either
like we're just going to take him out of
everything that that they operate
sort of as a cartel it's like they just
wait for the first mover
and then everybody sort of in a minute
does the exact same thing
well so jack dorsey actually explained
it um he wrote a tweet storm in which he
needed felt the need to defend the their
action to permanently
uh de-platform uh well you had a funny
you had a funny comment on what he said
because it's like he does these things
and then he suddenly feels very
emotional about what he's done and then
he
opens up about everything they make
these knee-jerk decisions that there's
like a violent reaction to it
and then because they don't they have a
blind spot with respect to their
you know their partisan biases and then
they realize oh wait a second we just
did something that
is a big deal and then he comes out and
gets very introspective and tries to
explain it
um at least he tries to explain it that
makes jack my my favorite oligarch
um but what what he said is that
when we twitter decided to ban
trump um we didn't think it was that big
a deal
because there were other places he could
go to basically get his free speech
right
and then all these other companies did
the same thing
um and and he's right if only one
company
were to you know de-platform you it
might not be that big a deal but when
all of them are doing it at the same
time
they're acting as effectively a speech
cartel now what
what jack said is that they that all of
us you know
didn't collude to make these decisions
but we emboldened each other that was
his word is emboldened
it sounds a lot to to me what we would
call
signaling an antitrust law where you
have a bunch of companies
that normally compete with each other
and therefore
are trying to make different decisions
not not all trying to get to the same
decision to try and compete with each
other
but signaling occurs when one company
does something and then you know all the
other companies follow suit
and that's basically what's happening is
that
is that with each incremental company
that decides
to to ban trump or whoever the pressure
builds on all the rest of them
to do the same thing otherwise they'll
be subject to
you know letter writing campaigns and
boy and all that kind of stuff
and so you know whether they're actively
colluding or not or whether it's merely
just a signaling you have the same
effect
which is a cartel so would you break
them up i mean would you use the force
of government to break up some of these
companies at this point
i would seriously look at it because i
think they are too powerful but i don't
think it's going to solve the speech
problem for this reason
imagine that google is busted up into
you know we have kind of google search
and then youtube becomes its own
property
and you know maybe there's like a third
division for
enterprise well i mean youtube's the one
that that we we sort of care about it's
we're not going to divide that property
up it's still going to be run
it'll just have a different cap table
it's going to have the same the same
executives
they all drink from the same sort of
monocultural fountain they all have the
same
ideological commitments and biases
they're subject to
most of the same pressures so i don't
know that if you
effectively increase the size of the
speech cartel
from five members to ten members i don't
know that that by itself does anything
um i think what we need and i'm not
expecting to get this
from congress anytime soon is um some
sort of common carrier
obligations imposed on these big tech
monopolies
uh this is a proposal that came from
richard epstein's professor
at the university basically what he says
is look if you're a gigantic monopoly or
a utility
you can't deny a service to somebody
based on their
creed you know that that's the
non-discrimination rule that we need
uh imagine if um you know like a common
carrier would be
something like a railroad you know where
it's it's a it's a natural
monopoly uh imagine if in the days of
the lincoln douglas debates
and you know they got around the country
by train imagine if
i don't know some oligarch cornelius
vanderbilt or something said you know
mr lincoln i don't i don't like your
your point of view in this debate i'm
going to deny you
service i don't want you to be able to
express your views well there's no way
that we would have let
that happen we wouldn't let somebody we
wouldn't let
monopolies be that powerful where they
can deny service to essential facilities
to people based on their creed and that
basically is the
the legislative fix here i think more
than
doing something like repealing section
230 which i think would hurt a lot of
small innovators right um
so so yeah but look you know i'm not
expecting to get that in the next two
years or
even four years so i'm guessing
generally speaking though you'd rather
have technological solutions to this
than governmental solutions
i would but um but i don't know that
we're going to get a technological
solution
because i do think that you know
monopolies are are real
i mean part of what i do as an investor
is trying to invest in the next set of
monopolies
and um you know
and you know that's what peter peter's
whole book uh zero to one is about is
there's two kinds of companies right
there right there michelle
yeah i mean there's two kinds of
companies right there's monopolies and
commodities you want to be a monopoly
well monopolies have incredible market
power
um i think it was it was fine
when those monopolies were lawfully
gained and were
trying to use their power to put their
thumb on the scale of american democracy
um you know and and it wasn't that long
ago that these big tech companies
you know uh w would state their their
uh commitment to neutrality i mean mark
zuckerberg gave i think a very good
speech
just a few years ago in 2018
in which he said that he said social
networks were were the fifth estate
you know the the the traditional media
historically was the fourth estate
i don't know i think one through three
were like i don't know they go back to
europe or something like the nobility
and the
peasants the people yeah the people yeah
yeah
anyway the fourth estate is traditional
media what zuckerberg said is that
social networks were the fifth estate
and that they posed a threat to the
people in power just like the
the fourth estate did and therefore it
needed to be protected
and i think he's right about that
and the the sad thing is that he
has felt the need to kind of move off
that position
um and engage in this sort of
censorship he's yeah when you see these
guys have to
go in front of congress you know when
you see jack or zuckerberg
i don't know if you know them personally
you know probably at least somewhere
in the circles or somewhat close but
when you see them have to
you know basically be arguing with
people who have so little understanding
of what the real issues are or any of
that stuff does it just
like drive you crazy to see it
it's a little painful you know because
the the people doing the the questioning
by and large
don't don't have the knowledge to or
ability to kind of interrogate
these ceos the way the way that they
should but
some of them do you know there have been
some interesting moments where the ceos
get
questioned and sort of dressed down i
mean there's a lot of like
theater it's very performative there's a
lot of grandstanding i mean
i don't really know how much progress
gets made in these
in these hearings but the point of it i
think is valid which is
you have these a handful of tech
oligarchs who now control
the public square and they've
appropriated
to themselves a vast power to decide
who has access and which views have
access and
which views they're gonna silence and
censor and basically ghost
and you know and no one elected them to
have that power and i think we should be
rightly concerned about that and i think
we should
question them about uh how they are
wielding that power
how much of an escalation do you think
it was when parlor
got nuked by amazon because that was
completely different
taking away servers than you know taking
away speech of an individual person
yeah i mean it was an escalation because
you had not just
um you know one person trump or his
supporters
being ghosted or d platform but you had
16 million parlor users or whatever is
99.9
of whom never did anything wrong you
know and that was a diminishment of
their free speech rights um
it was also i think uh unjustified
uh if if the justification for that
was that parlor was used in the planning
of the events of january 6. it was
clearly a scapegoating because
we now have fbi charging documents have
come out they found
226 cases the social networking site
that was
used 10x more than all the others was
facing
you know parlor was used one tenth of
the amount that facebook was but
parlor was you know was sort of an easy
and easy target to sort of scapegoat for
that
is that purely because of sort of the
cartel mindset that you were discussing
before like there's certain
there's you know however many people or
companies are involved in the cartel and
here's just this new guy so it's like
well they are competition there are 21
million people over there may as well
just take them out right
yeah i mean it's yeah i think they're an
easy target
um i think facebook clearly was eager to
deflect blame onto parlor there was
actually a pretty good article in the
washington post
about that um you know calling facebook
out on that
um pointing to the fact that they had a
lot more of this problematic content
than
than parlor did uh but yeah i mean it's
an
easy way for these big tech companies to
show that they're doing something
uh to control you know disinformation or
whatever that the powers that be now you
know are concerned about and
again i think this all goes back to the
fact that
uh these the big tech companies are very
worried about getting broken up right
now they don't want to get busted up and
so they're looking at curry favor
with you know the current administration
of washington so i can hear all my pure
libertarian fans in the back of my head
going okay you guys are talking too much
about government and antitrust and
regulation and breaking them up and all
that stuff
when you should be talking about
decentralization and and crypto
and everything else do you think there
are enough answers there
basically to solve a lot of this stuff
not in the near term i mean i'm a fan of
a lot of those crypto projects
but they're they're they're very much
projects um i would like to be able to
call them companies
um some of them i guess are companies
but they're still at a super early stage
um you know we're still building our
core infrastructure
of these sort of blockchain platforms to
my knowledge there has not been a
breakout application
built on top of any of these sort of
crypto platforms um
except if you want to you know except
for like bitcoin and then
d fire decentralized finance basically
financial speculation
um i think we're a long way off from
you know uh being able to run truly
decentralize
say speech apps uh with billions of
users
you know that that seems to me years off
if not decades and i'm not really
willing to
kind of wait that long to kind of have
the first amendment back
yeah and by the way that creates a whole
host of other problems right because
then you can put all sorts of
horrible stuff on there and once it's
there it's there and then
then you got a whole bunch of other
problems
yeah it's not it's not clear exactly
yeah i mean you need to have
some sort of regulation of these sites
and you know it's it's not that i want
there to be
anything goes i just would prefer to put
my faith in a venerable external
standard like
first amendment case law than to give
all all this power
to these unelected you know oligarchs uh
to make these decisions about
who gets to participate in american
democracy yeah so let's
let's shift a little to to lockdowns and
generally what's happened in the last
year because basically
the from almost the day we're posting
this it was pretty much a year ago right
now two weeks to flatten the curve
now it's a year later and people you
know biden's double masking and
you know california you still can't go
to indoor restaurants or go to the gym
and i guess we're gonna
partially open on april 1st or something
like that
but so much of this does seem attached
to big tech because they're letting you
say certain things about lockdowns and
not letting you say certain things is
your belief that there was just no
science behind the lockdowns at all
at any point well i guess at the very
beginning of covid
we didn't exactly know and so i don't
fault anyone too much for the decisions
that were made to lock down
back in march or april um we we simply
didn't know
as you'll recall i mean we were seeing
what was happening in italy the
hospitals were completely overrun
and so this idea of you know
of of locking things down to buy time so
that
our medical system didn't get overrun i
could understand the argument but
i think by this by last summer it was
becoming pretty clear
that lockdowns had an enormous cost to
them
and a very unclear benefit
and and i think as the year progressed
we had more and more data around this
certainly i think by the fall
anyone who is paying attention to that
data would have
you know should have been against uh
lockdowns i think
even by may i was tweeting that the
right policy was to go all in on mass
and
and to not do lockdowns so i mean i
think the data was
clear even by then so what do you think
was going on i mean
like in the mind we'll we'll get to
california more specifically but
generally like the ma
in the mind of gavin newsom in the mind
of of gretchen whitmer and the mind of
andrew cuomo these people that
you know in essence destroyed their
states in a lot of ways
versus texas and scary florida
like what do you think they were
thinking because i can't find any
science anywhere
i get what you're saying yeah for a
couple weeks you could try it and there
was this unsure moment and all that but
then after that
yeah i mean i don't know exactly
why they thought the political calculus
it would benefit them to to have this
extreme lockdown policy but i
but i think there was sort of a
collective failure of
um elite thinking um on covet and
really on many other issues and it
really you know you have to go back
to the who getting just about everything
wrong
from the beginning first um you know all
the way back in january saying that it
wasn't clear that there was human to
human contact
and then uh when it was clear that there
was they
um they greatly exaggerated the uh case
fatality rate by claiming that there
there weren't a lot of asymptomatic
cases um
you know we would later learn that there
was a huge
number of asymptomatic cases and
therefore we should you know the
infection fatality rate was more like
one-tenth the
the case fatality rate but they got that
wrong and sort of miseducated us and
then that led to
us thinking the the virus would be even
more severe than it was
um you know then then they were wrong
about mass
and so was you know vouching the cdc i
mean i wrote a blog post in early april
saying that mass should be the the
policy i thought that was
um that was the type of thing that was
low cost high benefit
um and the type of thing we should be
doing you know not not lockdowns
um and then you know they they got
lockdowns wrong and then they reverse
course on that and so there's just been
like
systematically i think the health
establishment just seems like they've
gotten everything
wrong here and it kind of
i mean just to tie it back to the
censorship thing
it shows how ridiculous it is to
maintain this position
that we can censor based on what experts
tell us
as youtube has been doing you know
youtube has been
censoring uh coveted uh
videos that have been put up that they
say uh contradict the who
apparently without irony because no one
has contradicted who more than the who
itself yeah um
so but but this idea that we can simply
rely on experts i think that
i mean it has to be that the that has to
be one of the big takeaways of covet is
that
we we cannot rely on these experts
they're just wrong way too often
and even you know fauci today and what
when the guidance we're getting today is
far too conservative
you know um fauci recently said that we
might have to wear mass until
2022 well why i mean
you know are you saying the vaccines
don't work um
because it seems to me that that the
messaging we're getting now is
effectively anti-vaxx
i mean if the vaccines work right
they've all become anti-vaxxers yeah
yeah if the vaccines work and biden has
now said that every american adult can
get one by the end of may
why would we need any more restrictions
after memorial day um and so i was in
favor of a mass policy early on but i do
not
support uh having a mass policy once
vaccines are available why
so you guys were just talking about
zeroism on on the show
and that it's a perfect segue for that
so can you explain that
yeah so jonathan chait actually came up
with it um
you know i think he's a writer for the i
guess
uh new yorker or i always forget about
the new yorker or new york magazine
i think it's a magazine okay yeah i
don't think i think um
i think he's probably uh uh i don't i
don't think he's red pill i think he's
he's pretty liberal but
um he might have called me racist once
or twice in a tweet
okay well he wrote one good call yeah
where
he uh coins this term uh zeroism and
what it basically is
is a refusal to deal with covid
um according to cost benefit analysis
and to insist
that even one case of covid is
unacceptable because
somebody can die and therefore we need
to have a policy of stamping out
every last case of kovit that that's
zero-ism
um the problem with zeroism is
that we're never gonna get rid of it i
mean there are always gonna be a
smattering of cases somewhere
it's a seasonal illness it's gonna
return and
the problem is that if every time it
returns we
now have the justification for the
politicians to
you know engage in like all these
emergency measures it gives them
extraordinary powers um so
yeah that that that's the thing i think
needs to be be challenged i mean
and look look at how heroism is being
used right now or has already i mean
obviously it was used
to justify the continuation of lockdowns
far beyond
what was necessary it's being used today
to keep schools closed you know you have
the education unions
saying that even after they're
vaccinated
if there are any cases of communities
spread for that there's even one case
of communities spread in a two-week
period they will not go back to school
so i mean this is a recipe for keeping
schools closed forever you had our
district attorney
in san francisco use covetously excuse
to empty out all the jails
you had gavin newsom use covetous excuse
for billions of dollars of no-bid
contracts to his political supporters
and so you know you have this suspending
of normal operating procedure
of the way that government works and if
we're going to suspend it every time
there's a
like one covet case well that that's not
going to work
are you worried though that that is the
the net effect of this thing that they
pushed us for a year and they whoever
they are but
you know in effect the system so boy we
can really get people to destroy their
own lives
and not see their family and not travel
and yet they'll do it in some places
like florida but we can get people in
california to act like sheep and there's
almost no pushback so so why not keep
pushing
well i think there's there's a lot of
push back now i mean look i think there
are a lot of people
who who are frightened of covet and
there will be some
ptsd about it but i think that you know
we're seeing now with the newsome recall
that i think people are very upset
about the restrictions and the the
the hypocrisy of it you know the fact
that newsom was
going to french laundry and you know
even during
the time when he was doubling down on
lockdowns and telling people they
couldn't go to the beach
which i mean that makes no sense because
there
there's been no real outdoor spread um
so you had that you know he was sending
his own kids to private school when you
know the public schools were
still closed and still are closed um so
i think people are pretty riled up by
this and i do expect
that people will want to go back
to the way things were pre-coveted very
very quickly
um and i i but i think the battle to be
joined over the next few months is the
battle against zeroism
and um and i and i and i expect that
we'll win that battle
um i expect that if newsom sticks to the
zeroest position
he will he will he will be defeated i
mean the recall election will be
in i think around august i think every
american who wants a vaccine will be
able to get one
in may and so i think
to the extent that california still has
all these restrictions
i think every week pressure is going to
build people in california look and say
well wait
none of these other states are doing
this stuff why are we still
restricted yeah are you worried though
are you worried though that basically
every week from now
till the election he's gonna open up
more and more and we'll we'll just kind
of forget right because we all have
short memories and
and even though we've got the two
million signatures i i know you're
you're bullish on the recall
that we'll just kind of forget well i
think i think newsom has already
um moved uh to the center uh because of
recall i mean there was a
there was this it was suspicious that
he he he reopened uh that he ended
lockdowns
for at least a big chunk of the
lockdowns um
right when the recall uh passed a
million signatures
so i think the recall has been creating
pressure on him to do the right thing
um i mean i think that's a good thing
that um that
it's it's that even if the recall
doesn't ultimately
pass uh i still think it's a good thing
that it's for it's
reminding the politicians that they work
for us
and um and for them not to not to forget
that
yeah before we move on to your fair city
of san francisco it just
i just hit me jonathan chait didn't call
me racist he did go after me for being a
small businessman
because i said i had like four i had
said i said i had several employees
and he felt that that wasn't enough to
be able to comment on
economics or something to that effect
anyway i it wasn't it wasn't a racist so
i want to
clean that up all right let's talk about
san francisco because uh you're not
happy
with what's going on in san francisco
and i've been there a couple times in
the last couple years
and i mean it's kind of disgusting the
amount of homelessness
the the drug use like it's pretty you
know there's an
app to track where human poop is like
how much worse does it get in a western
society city it's it's become totally
dystopian and a lot of people are
leaving like huge numbers of people left
during covet i don't even think we know
how many people have left i guess we'll
find out after covet and everything
reopens
exactly you know how damaged the city
has become but
it has become a huge problem and um
you know homelessness is out of control
crime is out of control
um the city's budget is completely
mismanaged um they they
were due for a giant budgetary shortfall
but they're going to be saved by
the 1.9 trillion dollar bill that's
coming out of washington
so we'll defer that day of reckoning for
another day but but
but the city is um squandering money
they was
recently revealed that they spent 16
million dollars providing
um 260 tenths for for homeless people so
there's a cost of
sixty one thousand dollars per tent um
you're saying that's not capital
efficient is that what you're telling me
yeah and i think i i mean i've heard a
number that the city on
on the whole if you look at all the
homeless services spends about 330 000
per year per homeless person so i mean
that's just like staggering
so can you explain why people seem to be
una
maybe it's a california thing it's the
nice weather i don't know that they
can't
seem to connect the bad
policies and all of the spending with
then
the stuff on the ground they can't
understand
that the more they put these people into
power the more that the homelessness
expands that the drug use expands
that the schools get worse that uh you
know businesses leave that
house prices get higher all of these
things and then they somehow always
blame the republicans even though
there's virtually no republicans in
power
in the state right yeah exactly
um well and that's part of the problem
is we haven't
for whatever reason we haven't had a
functional republican party in a long
time in california and so therefore
there hasn't really been a choice and we
kind of we've been living
under a one-party state and one-party
states generally don't
go very well so yeah and i but look i
i are voters waking up to this i think
so i mean
you know judging by my friends on the
pod they're all
they're all getting red pill to one
degree or another i'm not saying they're
ready to vote republican
but i think they're pretty upset and
they're looking for a different kind of
democrat let's put that way
listen the line i've been using it's
basically you're woker conservative it
doesn't mean you're a conservative like
a card-carrying member of the republican
party
i don't consider myself a republican but
it's pretty much everyone versus the
woke at the moment and we got to
set aside our differences to to clean up
some of this stuff
but you've been going after your d.a
chesa
bodine is that it boudin yeah chase
abuja
chase of bodine doesn't have the cojones
to debate you apparently
well i'm i was trying to goad him into a
debate because uh
yeah i mean i'd love to debate him about
what's going on in san francisco
um there's a number of these radical uh
da's now
la has one too gascone who was a
previous d.a
in san francisco who moved down to yeah
thanks for that okay
yeah exactly so you should be prepared
for
uh for what's coming uh they've done a
number of similar things
they've um i mean first of all they've
shown no interest in um
prosecuting misdemeanors so property
crimes
these are just quality of life crimes
that don't you know they don't affect
they don't have victims is the
the theory well they do if you have
enough of them
and you can't park a car in san
francisco without fear that's we've
broken into
uh that the uh there's now
been a a spate of home invasion
burglaries
um they're up some astronomical number
every year
uh you know there's um
and now there there's other kinds of
crimes um we've had
a number of people get killed recently
um i mean very sad cases where
you had i mean there's been just there's
been a few of these recently so on new
year's eve
there are two women who were killed they
were run down
by a driver of a stolen car who was on
drugs
fleeing another crime uh i think a
burglary he had committed
this the this this criminal troy
mcallister
he had been arrested five times in the
previous six months he'd been
let go every single time the d.a had
chosen not to prosecute charges and in
fact
he was paroled six months before in a in
a case where
he was in jail awaiting trial on um
on armed robbery he had used a gun and
uh in robbing a store and that was going
to be his third strike
and the new d.a chase of boudin came in
and pleaded him down to time
served and uh so you know you have a
case
with you know with new year's eve where
you know the
the decisions of this district attorney
led directly
to the deaths of these these two people
you had um
uh hannah abbey and elizabeth plott um
so anyway it was you know very sad case
uh and there there's a bunch of these
now i mean there
there's more and more you know victims
what do you think i mean just to give
the devil is due like what do you
think the d.a thinks he's doing
well his agenda is mass decarceration
and he's talked a lot about this he is
the
child of two weather underground uh
domestic terrorists who were put in jail
for
uh an armed robbery a brinks heist
that went wrong they ended up the people
in that group ended up killing
a couple of um police officers and and
guards
and so his dad is still in prison and he
he says his oldest poli
his oldest memory is visiting his
parents in prison and that
profoundly shaped his view of politics
and
the the criminal justice system and i
don't think it's an exaggeration to say
that his agenda is to release as many
criminals as possible
without real concern for the new victims
that's going to create the victims of
crime and it's a
it's a radical ideology um i mean
gascon's ideology is pretty similar
um then some examples are you know
with gasco and he won't prosecute three
strikes um
actually his own da's had to bring up a
lawsuit against him
to get uphold the judge the judge told
him he had to
to enforce it i don't expect him to put
a lot of effort into it
um he's prohibited prosecutors from
attending
both boudin and gasco and have
prohibited prosecutors
from attending parole hearings and so
there's no one to stand up in these
hearings for the victims
when we're talking about like you know
criminals who've done
you know horrible horrible crimes
killings and
and the victims groups are up in arms
because they used to have a prosecutor
go up there and speak for them
and because of that that you know we've
already had cases um in la where
murderers have been set free um
neither one of them will charge um
enhancements to sense
for you know gang enhancements gun
enhancements and
i've talked to prosecutors who that's a
very important important part of their
charging strategy
um and so you know they're really
um taking away all the the weapons that
prosecutors had at their disposal to
keep
you know these violent felons off off
the street
um and and and by the way there's a
there's a really perverse result that's
happened as well which is
i don't know if you remember but several
years ago the voters of california
passed prop 47 which downgraded a bunch
of uh property felonies to misdemeanors
and this was
marketed to all of us as you know
prisons were overcrowded and this was
excessive punishment well
the problem is that um
that these these pro these property
crimes like auto theft and stealing less
than 950 dollars
uh now that they're misdemeanors boudin
and gasco have absolutely no interest in
prosecuting them
i don't think the voters of california
would have voted for prop 47
if they thought they were
decriminalizing you know
theft which is effectively what they did
and so we now have this problem where
shoplifting
is basically it just we've had
walgreens has exited san francisco
because people would just come in there
with garbage bags and full and just load
them up
we covered it on my show last week 10
walgreens in the san francisco bay area
have closed and there's video of just
people literally just
like one arm the entire shelf and what
are you gonna do
right i mean look if you have a d.a who
says effectively that we're not going to
prosecute
that crime you've decriminalized it
you've made it legal
and so san francisco has basically hung
a burglar's welcome sign at the city
limits and
um you know so i'm not i'm not expecting
the crime stats to go in the right
direction after this so sex there are
people watching this going what are you
two schmucks doing in california give me
give me something hopeful
is there is there anything hopeful i
mean you know okay so maybe the recall
happens maybe
but do you see any real exit for san
francisco like how
bad does it have to get how much of that
has to be exported
you know a little down south to me here
in la like do you see any hope
well the people really are up in arms
about um
uh booting you know i think even i'd say
even more than new some
um there there's a recall underway for
chasa there's a recall
underway for gascone in addition to new
some
heck there's even a recall underway for
the san francisco school board
so um you know and by the way i'm
supporting all of them
so uh and and if there's anybody else
out there who wants to who wants to do a
recall let me know if you're willing to
put in the legwork and the time i'll
i'll uh write a donation to support you
so you know i i do think that you know
people are up in arms and they want to
change
and it's not partisan you know the first
thing that you know
chase said these other guys that what
they'd love to make it about is partisan
politics but
look when chaser gets recalled the mayor
london breed is going to appoint a
successor
that person is going to be a democrat um
but it's going to be a reasonable
democrat who just wants to enforce the
law
do a good job as district attorney
that's all we want we're not looking for
some political change we just want the
laws enforced
so you know we shouldn't let these guys
change the subject you know they're not
it's this has nothing to do with
partisan politics
yeah all right that that feels like the
right and that was sort of hopeful that
was kind of hopeful we just want laws
and force that seems sort of hopeful
right
yeah i know it's i mean all we're really
looking for here is
is civil society to basically be
restored i mean we don't have very high
standards i mean
we just want schools to open we want
um crime to be prosecuted you know we
want um
the the the government to stop shutting
everything down
we uh you know we we want um government
contracting to be done in a transparent
way that's not just a payoff to
political supporters
so i mean so i guess the hopeful thing
would be that things are so bad we don't
need
a lot to see a big improvement you know
um
we just need to get to some normality
here and i i do
think a majority of voters in the state
want this
and so if we can just marshal this
energy
to produce this change i think we will
get it real radical stuff
we don't if we don't you're not in miami
exactly real radical stuff a return to
living under the law
how bizarre all right well anyone that
wants to get involved with any kind
of recall effort it sounds like david
sacks is willing to write you a check so
his twitter
is at david sacks the podcast is the all
in pod which you can get anywhere
podcasts
are downloadable and david i thank you
for doing the show
yeah great to be here if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about tech instead of
non-stop yelling check out our tech
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell